I'm seeing a lot of people confused
about how Amy Schumer was casted as
Barbie originally and people not being
able to imagine her in like Margot
Robbie's place but when Amy Schumer was
casted she was not casted in this
version of the movie that we're going to
be getting this summer so let me explain
the history of the live-action Barbie
movie finally being made in 2009 Mattel
partnered with Universal Studios to make
the first ever live-action Barbie movie
however nothing came of this then in
2014 Mattel partnered with Sony to make
the film and two years later Amy Schumer
was casted by Sony as Barbie and she was
set to co-write the script however after
a few months Amy Schumer left because
she was having creative differences with
Sony Amy Schumer and Sony had very
different ideas for what they wanted
Barbie to be for example Amy Schumer
said that she wanted Barbie to be an
inventor and when she told us to Sony
they suggested that Barbie could invent
a pair of high heels that were made out
of jello Amy was only interested in
making the movie her way so she walked
and in 2018 Sony's option for the movie
expired so the Barbie project went to
Warner Brothers in 2019 Warner Brothers
casted Margot Robbie as Barbie and a
couple years later sign on to direct the
film and she co-wrote the script with no
one bound back so yeah Margot and Amy
were casted as Barbie three years apart
by different production companies with
different writers attached to the
project and completely different Visions
for the film and this might make Amy
Schumer's casting as Barbie less
confusing